ils avaient entre 3 et 20 ans lorsque de
laurent banide leur père est décédé
jean-yves marlène marcel et les autres
aux orphelins déterminé 50 ans après à
découvrir la vérité sur l'explosion du
vol af 200 doute accident ou attente un
nul ne le sait les éléments classés
secret défense en 1969 devait être
révélée en décembre
les autorités françaises ont prolonger
l'embargo jusqu'en 2029 cantine
indiquions que 7 10 ans s'est dit qu'on
s'est trop ma soeur on en parlait elle
est dépitée elle me dit j'ai 70 ans
aujourd'hui attendent 10 encore j'ai
avec la vie que j'ai menée il ya peu de
chances que je vois ses 80 ans jamais je
serai il avait été l'état c'est bien
beau le retrait des forces mais sont par
contre que ils ont détruit la vie de 11
enfants d'une épouse sans compter en
fait les autres passagers les 61 autres
passagers et avec leur famille ban idole
était membre du bureau du parti
communiste martiniquais
il a péri au côté d'un camarade
guadeloupéen oeuvre mon gène secrétaire
général du pc j ai deux hommes
revenaient d'un congrès international
communiste au chili à l'époque où
salvador allende préparer sa campagne
électorale en pleine guerre froide
y at il eu complot contre les
communistes antilles c'est le composent
et répété à liszt français et américains
ce n'est pas un accident c'est une
atteinte à la famille banide ne supporte
plus qu'on lui cache la vérité une
association vient tout juste de voir le
jour en métropole et un comité de
l'urbanisme
en martinique une pétition pour lever le
secret défense est en ligne sur jane x
org
la famille originaire de mornac et
jouhaud françois veut sensibiliser la
population et se dissipe le soutien des
élus c'est un homme qui avait au delà
justice et chats memory t
péan fouillis mais maintenant avec la
vérité ça permettiez que les gens
puissent poneys qui étaient sept ans le
3 décembre 69 62 personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans l'explosion du boeing avec 212
à caracas et la soif de vérité en
martinique comme en guadeloupe ne fait
que se renforcer au fil des années